i'm ariana debose from netflix's the
prom
and i am this week's agony aunt
for glamorous problem solved
[Music]
dear ariana i'm worried i'm going to be
single forever
how can i dust myself down and get
myself in the game
p.s do you have any great pickup lines
you can share
best koi clive or darling
made me for a drink and i'll tell you
all about it
that's the only pickup line i have so
you're welcome koi clive
darling you're not going to be single
forever but here's my best
advice to you confidence is like the
sexiest thing
ever so what i want you to do is date
yourself
get to know you and once you build this
inner confidence and you start to love
how fabulous
you are i would be willing to bet you
money things will start to change
because once your energy changes
people take notice and they flock right
to you all the boys will come
to the yard milkshake or no so you know
what i'm saying
you know when the lockdown's over go to
a movie buy yourself popcorn
buy yourself some jewels because you're
worth it
wow dear ariana i am not living my best
broadway life right now and i'm feeling
very low what are three steps so i can
channel my inner broadway diva and add
some zazz to my life
yours reclusive diva diana
you need to blast your favorite broadway
divas honey i'm talking about give me
some patti lupone give me the bernadette
the kristen chenoweth the adrian warren
i want you to sit down and write a love
letter to yourself
because after all you are the star of
your life and you deserve
fan mail and then you go and post it and
you're going to read it back
and remind yourself how awesome you are
dear ariana i have my eyes on someone's
special and i want to grab their
attention on the dance floor
what bewitching broadway inspired dance
move would you recommend
and best seductive sue
i would tell you to start off with like
a good fossy shoulder you know
a little shoulder to peek their interest
entrance them with your with your
spaghetti arms
i know it doesn't sound sexy but trust
me it is and then you need to like focus
on those hips honey
imagine i feel love is playing and
you're just like
get those hips going side to side nobody
can resist
a don summer spaghetti arm hip combo
you're welcome dear ariana my prompt
date promised to pick me up in a stretch
pip my right esk limo but instead
they have turned up in their old banger
what is my
best escape plant kind regards fuming
freddy fuming freddy
i too would be fuming this is where i
tell you that
a good accessory will take you far get
yourself a good bag you put your cell
phone a lipstick and a 20
bill in it your escape plan is uber
and if uber's not working call yourself
a cab and use that 20
bill honey and don't feel bad about it
you're not being rude anybody who shows
up in a pimp my ride
is limo they're not doing it right it's
okay don't feel bad
dear ariana i'm dealing with hate and
bullies
how do i shut them down would you
recommend a sassy put down or just
a simple and effective death stare with
a hair flick
in real life help get my own back
gail normally i do recommend sass but
bullying is not to be tolerated mama i
want to encourage you
to speak up reach out to someone ask for
help
bullying is never tolerated period
point-blank end of story
there's a great website for bullying
advice
called bullying uk um there are great
resources
on online and and please please use them
you deserve the best you deserve the
world and don't let people dull your
sparkle
dear ariana my partner's mother has
become a monster-in-law
oh no how can i get my revenge and take
her down
yours enraged emma okay
auntie ari says your responsibility is
to your partner
all you need to do is be on the same
page
with your person what we all only
require
is the love and devotion of our person
in this world
as far as your monster-in-law kill that
queen with kindness
because ain't nobody got time for her
extraness
you feel me love you for more
problem-solved videos subscribe
to glamour uk channel now xoxo ahri